Apple's Mac Studio with the ultra chip
is it worth the money six months later
today we find out by breaking down all
of the issues that I've experienced over
the last six months reviewing who should
buy the Mac Studio with the ultra chip
versus who should buy it with the max
chip who really needs that Ultra why I
personally bought the ultra and finally
of course is it worth the price tag
what's going on guys my name is David
tomich I'm a registered architect here
in Western Australia and today we're
going to be looking at the Mac Studio
Ultra through six months of user
experience now this is my daily driver I
have a Max version at the office as well
so I have a good comparison on both of
these devices so let's get started by
looking at the issues I've had over the
last six months with this device one of
the biggest issues I had was the Mac
Studio and the studio display decided to
stop talking to each other first they
wouldn't produce any sound through the
actual display then the display wouldn't
work at all so this kind of freaked me
out because it was quite early on into
the user experience audience I had to do
quite a bit of Googling on my phone to
actually understand how I could fix this
because I couldn't use the computer
itself to understand what was wrong
eventually what I had to do was unplug
the display from the studio and fully
de-power both systems then reboot as a
hard reset to actually be able to turn
them back on Apple has actually
identified that this was a problem early
on and released a software update for
both the mac and the studio so this
hasn't happened ever since I also found
at the start that everything was still
running on Rosetta 2 and even though
Apple said it would run perfectly fine
there was so many problems I'll use twin
motion as an example for those of you
who don't know twin motion is a
three-day real-time rendering software
for architecture at the start it would
crash continuously I'd use it for about
five minutes and it would crash it
wouldn't just crash the program it would
crash the whole computer you would have
to reboot the entire system to be able
to bring everything back online so for
the first two to three months of owning
the Mac Studio this this was the biggest
burden now the programs that we're still
running on Rosetta 2 at the early days
and still probably are running today
actually ran significantly better which
was a huge Improvement but the problem
was they were still all running on a
rosetta 2. they weren't native they
weren't using the full power of the M1
chips and they were just kind of a
little bit better for the price tag a
little bit better isn't really worth it
so it took a long time for anybody to
even start introducing Apple silicon
native programs and many of the programs
that I still use today including
archicad which I use every single day is
not available for Apple silicon natively
well this brings me to my next point
should you buy that Mac Studio with the
ultra chip or should you buy it with the
max chip well funnily enough I purchased
myself the ultra version and for
everybody in the office I purchased the
max chip now with very good reason and
justification myself personally I plan
on keeping this computer for eight to
ten years which means I'm going to get a
very long lifetime out of this device
whereas from a commercial point of view
we only keep our devices for about five
years until they can no longer keep up
with the demand of the office the main
justification of why we purchased the
max instead of the ultra for the office
is simply for the fact everything is
still running on Rosetta 2 and will
continue to run on Rosetta 2 for a good
two to three years from now which means
if you think about it best case scenario
everything transitions to Apple silicon
maybe 2024 2025 that leaves us with only
two years of Peak Performance on those
devices meaning we've just spent
thousands and thousands of dollars for a
computer that will only really give us
two years worth of its best ability
whereas for me because I plan on keeping
it for significantly longer that means I
do get an extra six years of Peak
Performance out of this device when
everything does transition to Apple
silicon I think being an early adopter
into the Apple silicon chipset was you
know hit and miss a little bit because
you got the added benefits of the speed
performance but not a hundred percent of
what it could actually achieve so even
now six months later with the ultra it
still isn't showing its true colors on
all programs but when it does and when
it truly accelerates and becomes fully
native across everything that you can
imagine who actually needs the M1 Ultra
or potentially the M2 Ultra in the near
future well the answer is actually quite
simple if you're a creative working on
large projects you need the ultra it's
that simple the ultra can handle larger
files larger file types and it can
handle a larger diversity of programs
running simultaneously now if you're a
medium-sized Creator then you can
definitely get away with the max version
even if you're running some small files
some Photoshop some illustrator things
like that Apple silicon with the max
chip will be completely fine but once
you get into that high level of
detailing let's say you're designing
Apartments giant skyscrapers you're
probably going to need something like
the ultra if not something even more
powerful and by creators and creatives I
don't just mean Architects I mean
Architects designers Engineers creators
of All Sorts even if you're a graphic
designer an individual artist a
photographer a videographer all of these
fall under my creative category anybody
that isn't literally just working on
Word Excel and Outlook then you need
something powerful if you are running
just word excel Outlook and you know
general office work you probably don't
need anything above the typical M1 chip
you can get away with the base model of
what apple offers so to wrap this up is
it actually worth the price tag the
simple answer is absolutely yes the
Apple Studio with the ultra chipset is
phenomenal now that the market is
starting to catch up to the actual
Hardware it was a very long time coming
working on Rosetta 2 and slowly
transitioning in to the native apps but
as they've transitioned you can see huge
performance improvements across the
entire system last week I actually
tested rcad 26's Apple silicon beta
version on the device and it ran
significantly better it was producing
numbers that I never thought would be
possible by simply transitioning from a
native Intel or running on Rosetta 2 all
the way to Apple silicon so the numbers
are incredibly impressive once it does
transition and because it has been six
months now and well over a year since
Apple silicon has been introduced to the
world the market has caught up and will
continue to catch up over the next six
months over the next 12 months if you're
looking to buy the Mac Studio with the
ultra chip and you are a creator with
large files I definitely recommend it
for you anyway that's all for me today
guys thank you so so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed the video if you did
make sure you check out the playlist to
the side of me for more great
architectural and Tech content if you
loved the video make sure you smash that
subscribe button down below as well as
the like button for the YouTube
algorithm and like always I'll see you
next Monday